en france six mois après l'entrée en
vigueur de la nouvelle loi sur l'entrée
et le séjour des étrangers dans notre
pays il apparaît un certain nombre de
difficultés d'application notamment pour
ce qui concerne les parents étrangers
qui ont des enfants nés en france donc
français mais qui pour eux mêmes ne
parviennent pas à obtenir une carte de
résident en quête valérie gager luc
baechler johanna un an et française sa
maman est les malgaches
arrivé en france en 90 avec un visa de
tourisme cette jeune femme se trouve
aujourd'hui dans une situation
paradoxale son visa n'étant plus valable
elle est en situation irrégulière et ne
peut donc obtenir de titre de séjour
cependant en tant que mère d'un enfant
français elle ne peut être reconduite à
la frontière
elle souhaite rester en france si elle
sait les régulariser parce qu'il ya des
zaz et travail que qui est prêt à
attendre et à dessein des patrons qui a
donné les premiers stamos avant
l'adoption en août dernier de la loi sur
la maîtrise de l'immigration
il suffisait que les parents soient
entrés régulièrement en france pour
qu'ils obtiennent un titre de séjour
désormais ils doivent plus être en
situation régulière au moment où il
demande une carte de résident à ces
personnes en leur parfait il premier
avec un visas ils partent en leur disant
vous êtes domicilié en france au brésil
a donc celle à l'impasse
certains parents sont repartis chercher
un visa mais faute de pouvoir l'obtenir
ils sont restés bloqués dans leur pays
d'origine alors beaucoup ne prennent pas
ce risque
il reste en france mais sans titre de
séjour ils n'ont pas le droit de
travailler
pas de sécurité sociale ni expulsables
ni régularisables ils ont le sentiment
que la loi à ses deux départs en
clandestin si maintenant un exemple des
rapports parfois soupçonneux que nous
français nous entretenons avec les
assurances dans le cas qui nous est
présentée maintenant il s'agit de
l'explosion d'une canalisation de
chauffage diffusant de la vapeur dans
l'ensemble d'un immeuble et endommageant
plusieurs appartements s'agit